earlier this year the Honda Jazz was
rated one of Europe's safest cars based
on the results of tests carried out by
the Euro endcap program we thought we
take a closer look at the Jazz one of
the criteria used in the crash tests is
the performance of the car's driver
assists the Honda Jazz offers the city
emergency brake assistant
the Jazz features a new longer platform
and a wider wheel base it's not very big
just over 3.8 meters long but the
current model has a lot more room inside
than before the taillights sort of look
like they belong on a Volvo the third
brake light has been integrated into the
spoiler the interior looks a lot roomier
you can choose the new infotainment
option Honda Connect you can also run
the system from buttons on the steering
wheel
the cupholders to the left of the
steering column are an especially
welcome addition the center console is
chock full of goodies including a
12-volt outlet and HDMI and USB ports
auto tester emanuelle Schaefer is going
to show us the backseat area gah there's
plenty of room back here plenty of room
for your needs
and it's comfortable too that's
important for long trips so a clean baby
if you don't have to worry about
passengers you can fold up the backseat
to create a big storage area there's
enough room for small items of furniture
or even a bike so a few clinical menorah
nahi nothing get along fine but now
Emmanuel is going to show us the trunk
there's 350 liters of space here ah
that's pretty big there's even enough
room to sit down and there should be
plenty of space for all your shopping
tonight but if you need more room just
flip a couple of switches to create even
more space to 1300 liters in fact that's
kindly say nothing
so let's see how the jazz performs on
the road Honda has introduced a new
platform and chassis and that gives the
car a more dynamic field plus they've
reduced its overall weight and increased
body stability this model of the Jazz
comes only with the 1.3 liter petrol
engine
but a man will points out that you can
choose from two transmissions a
six-speed manual or a continuously
variable transmission CVT the Honda Jazz
can go from 0 to 100 km/h in just over
11 seconds it can reach a top speed of
190 km/h and as far as fuel efficiency
is concerned the Jazz gets 100
kilometers on 5 liters of gas in Poltava
the manual says the Jazz handles pretty
well on the road and it holds the line
comfortably through corners the engines
a little low on torque so it takes you a
while to notice the change after you
shifted gears missing from 40 back
overall a manual has mixed feelings
about the Honda Jazz its design reminds
him a lot of the Civic but that's just a
matter of personal taste a motor the
engines not very powerful particularly
under 3,000 rpm Velen doc but the Jazz
is pretty right whether you're sitting
in the back seat or eluding a bunch of
stuff into the trunk and you can even
have more space by reconfiguring the
seats that's one of the cars big
advantages
the price for the Honda Jazz in Germany
is just under 16 thousand euros and if
you include all the options that we did
in our test model plus a few extras the
price could easily top twenty thousand
you